RESORTING TO DESPERATE MEASURES,
UNBELIEVABLE MEASURES TO SAVE
THEIR ANIMALS.
IVAN WATSON IS OUT FRONT IN HONG
KONG.
>> Reporter: PETS ON PRIVATE
JETS.
THIS MAY SOUND LIKE A RIDICULOUS
LUXURY, BUT CHARTER FLIGHTS FOR
PETS ARE A BOOMING COVID
PANDEMIC BUSINESS IN HONG KONG.
AN INTERNATIONAL FINANCIAL HUB
THAT IS INCREASINGLY CUT ITSELF
OFF FROM THE OUTSIDE WORLD WHILE
TRYING TO KEEP COVID CASES HERE
AT ZERO.
>> WE HAVE BEEN OVERWHELMED WITH
THE AMOUNT OF REQUESTS TO FLY
PETS OUT OF HONG KONG.
>> Reporter: WHY DO YOU THINK
THE DEMAND IS GOING UP?
>> BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING AND A LOT OF PEOPLE NEED
TO MOVE THEIR PETS.
>> Reporter: CHARTER JET
OPERATORS SAID DUE TO GOVERNMENT
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS AND
TEMPORARY BANS ON DOZENS OF
AIRLINES, THERE ARE ALMOST NO
COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS AVAILABLE TO
TRANSPORT PETS.
THE MOST RELIABLE ALTERNATIVE?
PRIVATE PLANES COSTING AROUND
$22,000 FOR A PERSON AND THEIR
DOG TO FLY DIRECT FROM HONG KONG
TO NEW YORK.
>> PEOPLE LOVE THEIR FUR BABIES.
WE'RE HERE TO HELP THEM.
>> Reporter: THE PRESSURE ON
SOME PET OWNERS MOUNTED THIS
MONTH WHEN HONG KONG AUTHORITIES
MADE A STARTLING ANNOUNCEMENT.
THE CITY'S TOP OFFICIAL BLAMED
AN OUTBREAK OF THE DELTA VARIANT
ON HAMSTERS.
>> THIS ISN'T A JOKE.
THE HONG KONG GOVERNMENT CLAIMS
THAT HAMSTERS IMPORTED FROM THE
NETHERLANDS GAVE COVID TO A PET
SHOP WORK AT THIS STORE.
THEY HAVE SINCE ORDERED THE
CLOSURE OF EVERY PET SHOP IN THE
CITY THAT SOLD SMALL ANIMALS.
THEY'VE ALSO CALLED AND KILLED
MORE THAN 2500 HAMSTERS, WHITE
RATS, RABBITS, CHINCHILLAS, AND
GUINEA PIGS.
>> Reporter: THE AUTHORITIES
TOLD RESIDENTS WHO HAVE BOUGHT
HAMSTERS ON OR AFTER DECEMBER
22nd TO HAND THEM OVER TO BE
EUTHANIZED.
PROMPTING SCENES LIKE THIS.
WHERE ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS
TRIED TO INTERCEPT PET HAMSTERS
BEFORE THEIR HANDOVER TO
OFFICIALS.
>> PET OWNERS SHOULD NOT BE
WORRIED ABOUT CATCHING COVID
FROM THEIR ANIMALS.
>> Reporter: RESEARCHER AND
VETERINARIAN VANESSA BAR SAID
THE HONG KONG GOVERNMENT
OVERREACTED.
>> WE KNOW SO FAR IN THE
PANDEMIC, THERE HAVE BEEN OVER
350 MILLION CASES OF COVID
REPORTED IN HUMANS AND THE FIRST
350 MILLION CASES THAT HAVE BEEN
REPORTED, THERE HAVE BEEN NO
CONFIRMED CASES OF TRANSMISSION
OF COVID FROM PEOPLE'S PETS BACK
TO HUMANS.
>> Reporter: AFTER MONTHS WITH
ALMOST NO INFECTIONS, THE WALLS
OF HONG KONG'S COVID FORTRESS
SEEM TO BE CRUMBLING.
IN 48 HOURS, MORE THAN 4800
PEOPLE TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID
AT THIS HONG KONG HOUSING
ESTATE.
THIS ISN'T BEING LINKED TO
HAMSTERS.
ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS AND SOME
PET OWNERS ARE STILL SPOOKED.
>> THE CONCERN REALLY IS, IF IT
STARTS WITH HAMSTERS, WHERE DOES
IT GO NEXT?
WILL WE SEE COMPANION ANIMALS
SUCH AS CATS AND DOGS BE ROPED
INTO THIS?
THAT'S A REALLY REAL FEAR THAT
PEOPLE HAVE.
>> Reporter: THIS WOMAN HAS
GOTTEN A SURGE OF INQUIRIES FROM
PET OWNERS LOOKING FOR SEATS ON
PRIVATE PLANES IN JUST THE LAST
WEEK.
>> WHAT IS THE ALTERNATIVE?
IF YOU'RE A PET OWNER AND